at the core of your book and your work
is the language program can you describe
what it is
sure so
Lang lens is a mathematician
it's a name of a mathematician Robert
langlands
canadian-born
still alive he is was a professor at The
Institute for advanced study that we
talked about where Einstein and girdle
and other great scientists have worked
in fact he used to occupy the office of
Albert Einstein at The Institute for
advanced studying
so he uh
in in the late 60s
he came up with a set of ideas which
captivated a lot of mathematicians
several generations of mathematicians by
now
which came to be known as the language
program
and what it is about is connecting
different fields of mathematics which
seemed to be far away from each other
for example number Theory which as the
name suggests deals with numbers
and various equations
with you know like x squared plus y
squared equals one
um and on the other side
harmonic analysis
something that
any music lover can appreciate because
the sound of a symphony can be kind of
decomposed into sounds of different
instruments and each of those sounds can
be represented by a wave like this like
a sine function
those are the harmonics they actually
the period of a harmonic periods of
different notes are different it
correspond to different notes and
different instruments different
semitones if you will
but they all combine together into
something
diff something special which which is
not cannot be reduced to any one of
those so it's the mathematically it's
the idea that you can decompose a signal
into
um as a collection as a simultaneous
oscillation of several Elementary
signals that's called harmonic analysis
so what language found is that some
really difficult questions
in number Theory can be translated into
much more easily tractable questions in
harmonic analysis that was his initial
idea but what happened next surprised
everybody that the kind of patterns that
he was able to observe the kind of
regularities that he was able to observe
which were quite surprising
were subsequently found in other areas
of mathematics
for example in geometry
and eventually in quantum physics
so in fact
Ed Witten who is a kind of a dean of
modern theoretical physicists the
professor at The Institute for advanced
study as well
got interested in this subject I
described in my book how it happened
and he was one instrumental in um
in Bridging the Gap between this
patterns in found in physics and in
Geometry finding kind of a
substrate a kind of a super stratum if
you will it's kind of uh over our kind
of a way to connect these two things
kind of a bridge between these two
Fields so I subsequently collaborate
with Witten on this and this has been
one of the major themes of my research
um it's sort of
I always found it interesting
to connect things to unite things
when I was younger I couldn't I couldn't
understand why
but I was always interested in
when when not in working in specific
field
by kind of but kind of cutting across
fields
and um
and then I we discovered that for
instance I took some people who know
what happens in this field but
don't know what happens in their field
and or conversely and then I would I
would like find it
imperative
to go out and explain to them to the
different sides what this is all about
so that more people are aware of this
hidden structures of this hidden
parallels if you will
so that has been sort of a theme in my
research and so I guess you know now I
kind of understand more why it's kind of
a balance you know like what we talked
about earlier
so can you
elucidate a little bit how what are the
mathematical tools that allow you to
connect these uh different continents of
mathematics
right is there something you can convert
into words that language was able to
find find and you were able to explore
further
I would say what it suggests is that
there is some and a hidden principles
which we still don't understand my my
view is that we still don't know why
that we can prove some instances of this
uh correspondences and connections
but we still don't know the real
underlying reasons which means that
there is a newly there is a certain
layer
beneath the surface that we see now
it is like the so the way I see it now
is like this
that there is something
three-dimensional like this bottle but
what we are seeing is this projection
onto the table and projection to wall
and then we can map things from one
projection to another and say oh my God
that's incredible
but the real explanation is that both of
them are projections of the same thing
and that we haven't found yet but that's
what I want to find so that's what
motivates me I would say
from number Theory to Geometry to
quantum physics so there is this one
thing which has different projections
except it's not just a table and the
wall but they're like many different
walls if you will so what is the
philosophical implication that there is
commonalities like that across these
very disparate fields
it means that what we believe are the
fundamental elements of
uh of mathematics are not fundamental
there is something Beyond it's like we
previously thought that atoms were
indivisible
then we found out that there is a
nucleus and electrons and the nucleus
consist of protons and neutrons then we
thought okay protons and neutrons must
be Elementary
now we know they consist of quarks
so it's about kind of finding the quarks
of mathematics
of course beyond that there's maybe even
more which was my initial motivation to
study mathematics by the way right so
quarks was the first time you fell in
love with understanding the nature of
reality yeah